sistema una telecamera 5 milioni e mezzo
dai signori questo sarà l'anno della
patente io lo dico due eventi
io ve lo giuro e io ho la patente ok
promesse
sei pronto sempre cosa faremo uno
studiato dai tenere questa è la mia
tecnica cioè è una tecnica pura anche
utilizzato anche alle superiori
eccolo eccolo eccolo là ci siamo ci
siamo
niente preannunciato 8a contro ogni mia
singola legge mentale poterti dire che
sono promosso perché anche l'ultima
volta felicità f5 noi bocciata quindi
per me dirti che sono promosso è
un'eresia
perché poi non è mai così però io reputo
impossibile che io sia stato bocciato
perché erano durante veramente ma adesso
vi faccio vedere ragazzi a casa non ci
credono adesso vi faccio vedere i miei
quiz della patente con la mia up di quiz
la patente no se guardate la scuola da
queste labbra
ok allora adesso vi faccio vedere questa
cosa tutto il mio allenamento nelle
ultime due settimane ha dato questi
risultati qua allora questi sono quelli
vecchi e dulko ad acqua iniziato il
periodo di studio da qua sono tutte
verde 61 voli dei verdi tutte verdi e
queste sono molto erano molto più
difficili quelle che mi è capitato
adesso quindi non è possibile non è
possibile se sono bocciato veramente la
mia vita una barzelletta e lo è già
basta basta basta basta fare qui basta
mi sono rotto il carrello e chi li
filano gli uffici sono a guarira in 45
di fila azzeccate e questa era molto più
facile di queste 45 quindi non può
essere
e arrivato il messaggio se sono stato
promosso meno e non lo so ancora perché
a questo il messaggio
fabietto patente mi scrive lo apriamo
insieme noi mostro cazzi miei che devo
farti guidare tre errori promosso
[Musica]
però adesso che si fa a borno sono un
suo marito lo sono
signori allora siamo in un momento
storico perché stiamo andando a fare la
prima guida una volta che passi la
teoria tu devi fare almeno sei guide con
la macchina per poter prendere la
patente per il buon giallo che mi
accompagnerà
e dura incredibile ovviamente lorenzo
non è che si mette a fare la patente in
un momento storico del tutto tranquillo
no corona vyrus il bari però intano
queste parole bagnabile non si può dire
ora
beh umbrella corporation
però meglio perché c'è meno gente in
giro che quindi meno morti
io ma dopo il sì non impari mafiose nei
imparo belle ma che sarebbe importante
averla poi tanto non è mai quello di
distruggerlo
va bene ma qui ma poi si comincia
malissimo o addirittura la seconda ronza
rocchi
basta
[Musica]
parcheggi in retro tra i one
spaventatissimi è chiaro c'è ma i file
raw e il giorno e il giorno bravo il
giorno dai dai che vediamo le reti
complessive dalle 6 del mattino
l'importo mai meglio meglio sveglio
dalle 66 bello vinta poi ci mettiamo una
parola fine a questa purga durata 7 no
sette anni e mezzo oggi mettiamo la
parola fine fatto nella stradina come
quando dico di vincolo che trigger del
momento dell'esame mi stavo ripassando
la le precedenze che non mi ricordo
perché il momento dell'esame poi altri
con gli episodi dalla destra sinistra
precedente sai quando in matematica fa i
due più due
ovviamente si veda vediamo come dice uno
dei miei personaggi degli anime
preferiti
arrivederci però come fine
dov'è allora ragazzi il problema è stato
il problema è stato singolare perché
mentre ovviamente non ho potuto portare
perché non si può portare jean pierre
registra mentre pare davvero il problema
i propri grosse stato stato e pellicce
sull'unità di quanto avere questo pezzo
di plastica sia in tutta la mia vita a
ruota attorno a questo pezzo di plastica
cioè negli ultimi sette anni capitoli
del fatto è che mentre guidano è stato
ring è stata un'esperienza incredibile
praticamente il tipo mi ha fatto delle
domande prima di guidare guidare non c'è
stato problema è che è incredibile però
prima di salire in macchina tipo chi ha
fatto delle domande sono state queste
quali sono i liquidi che bisogna
controllare la macchina motore acqua a
l'acqua dei gap dai dati aderci
cristalli un liquido che di contro la
quale è anche accessori ho paura che non
mi facesse entrare in macchina per
questo e invece poi mettono di mente
nella sala con i tergicristalli eh sì ok
va bene prendere la macchina perché non
son liquido ed agilità dai va verso del
pesto e stato incredibile bene adesso
sono emozionato adesso manca la macchina
assieme proprio il casto grosso
l'abbiamo fatto quindi come allora non
so quando vedrete questo video perché è
il discorso è stato che abbiamo un
miliardo di click una mente l'insieme di
tutto questo percorso del 2003 mirati
con questa missione nel 2000 22 però
spero che questa odissea della patente
mi sia piaciuta a me no insomma vado a
buttare tutte le cose che avevo
a studiare per tanto non mary cohr
doppio tagiko in un buon bonino buon
ciao
[Musica]